every time i have a kitkat it's usually
like it's usually in like you know it's
like two kitkats together right yeah and
right
split it i don't know literally just
grab and just
stop it
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste
i am boy and with me today are boys
hello that's me the usual one yay how
are you doing
boys i'm doing well boy i am tired
i've just been building furniture for
the past week and she's just been going
through like the entire ikea
like catalonia i've just been building
that right pretty much like it's like
never it's it's just like am i like a
respawn point for ikea photography
because like
every time i build one another one just
responds the next day i'm like
what's in the most satisfying build wait
what is the most annoying furniture to
build in general i want all your boys
ikea anything not from ikea
i sometimes go there okay what's like
the item that is always most annoying
uh i have my own thoughts on this i've
already decided
i don't know maybe i mean i've built
desks
shelves chairs tables
i built everything i've built it
what was your answer connor since you
seemed to have one okay so
i bet oh [ __ ] let's get a little spill
beds can be annoying
right beds get beds can be quite
frustrating if you get the really cheap
beds
of [ __ ] they they're like they're either
like a two by two rubik's cube or a
64 by 64 gauntlet cube you know what you
know what you need to get what we got
koala beds is it a shout out
are you being sponsored by koala bears
right now no no yeah i don't know
because i will say i did sleep on uh
chris's couch and actually can we get
some tissues
yeah because chris because chris has
like the
bed right i think by them yeah and i was
like
chris's chris is chris is sofa sofa is
nicer than my bed
yeah because we i mean i remember when
we just moved here i just bought like
whatever was
the cheapest option on yeah biggest
mistake
and now i regret it because at that time
it's like whenever you move into a new
place the
the most difficult part is just the
amount of upfront money you put down you
look at your bank account you're just
like
oh that's a really low number and that's
a really big number i'm giving away
all at once right so do i really need a
a microwave i'm sure i can just
slap my chicken hot you know yeah that's
how i just rub it across the ground
whatever like i'll survive yeah yeah i'm
finally getting rid of my uh
my laundry machine uh washing machine
yeah we get we're getting rid of
ourselves
yeah yeah i got rid of my my cockroach
infested one
yeah yeah it is nice to get rid of it
and get a new one get something nice you
can afford it
i'm taking the old one from this studio
are you yeah
yeah wait what are you actually yeah
because we have to get rid of it and i
was like well i'll take it
this is better than the one i have wait
are you actually taking else yeah yeah
this is the first time hearing about it
yeah what what do you think was going to
happen with it
i thought we're just going to get rid of
it oh i was going to get rid of it well
no why would you do that i'll just take
it well no because if you go to like big
camera or like
yodabashi and you buy like a fridge from
there they have a free service where if
you have
a fridge already they'll get rid of the
old one for you yeah but
so i was just gonna utilize that what to
get rid of my fridge
yeah have you so why don't why did you
still have your old fridge i thought you
bought a new one no no no no
no my washing machine washing machine oh
washing oh washing machine okay
if you buy a new fridge on amazon
there's a service that that's what i did
okay that they'll take the old one away
yeah you can do that with your fridge
wait wait so you're gonna take so
goddamn long to get some t-shirts
why did it take two of you we're
literally asked for this
like five minutes ago i just thought it
was like a swat team sting operation
i just saw the most chaos i just saw
ashley come in doing like the john
travolta like
we have two staff and it took both of
them five minutes to get some tissues in
the other room
wait wait wait wait wait wait hold on
hold on we're gonna go can we go back to
the whole for each thing okay okay so
wait
okay i got rid of my fridge by doing
that service where i bought a new one
right to get rid of it right yeah but
wait but did you say you were gonna take
alfred no i'm taking our
washing machine oh your washing machine
i thought you were going to take my
fridge from my house
how would i do that shall we when did we
decide
explain to me the logistics you were
just like
i was like i was like did this man
really just be like so yeah i'm taking
your fridge
i'm just i decided i'm taking your
fridge
i'm taking a page out of my ancestors
books and just taking things
other people's houses i thought you were
taking the fridge from the studio no no
no no no i already have a you guys know
i have a new fridge
i know you know that's why i was so
[ __ ] like a new fridge you have to be
you have to be specific
what the [ __ ] i literally just got this
fridge it's a great fridge
okay great great average fantastic
because i i this is the first time i'm
hearing about you getting a new fridge
so that's why
i'm not getting a new fridge oh my god i
already have a new fridge
i'm so when did you buy the fridge like
four months ago
wait the coffee brings to my house the
cockroach one yeah but i also okay
remember when i just said you see
i i swear to god five minutes ago you
just said i still got the cockroach
fridge i have the laundry machine
the cockroach laundry machine i have
wait would you have it
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait the only story
i've only heard about the cockpit fridge
machine
cockroach laundry machine as well okay
so when i got
my fridge it was a it was a two-for-one
deal
you know so yeah yeah i know about that
oh okay so they both had cockroaches in
them
yeah well no but they were they were in
the same building they were
you said your washing machine also had
cockroaches yeah
there might have been one or two in
there i can't remember rewind the clip
right now
i speak to someone on craigslist the
sauna fridge and a laundry machine is
what you call it
a laundry machine they both came here in
the same truck they both came from the
same place
frankly if your fridge had you know
there was like a good 15
20 cockroaches in this fridge i'm not
i'm not you know
at that point i'm not giving you the
benefit of the doubt with any of your
other appliances
like how can you live with that many
[ __ ] this is vile this is
actually violent yeah i don't understand
go go go how big were the cockroaches
because i've
i've never seen like cockroaches in
japanese in japan
uh like there was like one or two that
were pretty big chunkers but there a lot
of them were the little baby ones yeah
uh but like the worst part was this is
very much a gross warning i know i've
spoken about this before but like
like when i when i ripped off all the
felt and stuff yeah there was a hole in
the felt and i
i i put it in like a [ __ ] uh like
bleach stuff i know that doesn't kill
them but it's one of the bleachers the
fridge how did you kill them uh most of
them were already dead oh
okay there was so many dead cockroaches
inside of this fridge yeah it's a yikes
it's pretty disgusting
and i paid for that i paid for that
i can't believe that that's what you get
man for using what craigslist craigslist
never again
you know i was the one time where i was
like i'll give craigslist a chance
i'll give craigslist a chance i'll try
because have you ever dealt with
cockroaches in the uk
at all because like i remember like for
most of my life i
i had just never seen a cockroach
because like the uk is pretty clean in
terms of
imagine the privilege of living in a in
a sanitary home
cockroaches what is that i saw a fair
amount when i moved to london but
oh really in wales i didn't see many
yeah because i remember my my very first
cockroach experience was actually not in
the uk but it was in thailand right
and uh i remember because like my house
is not like in the city center
it's like right on the outskirts and
we're near like a lot of like uh
like not not a forest but like a lot of
like grassland
basically so we're we're like right out
in the outskirts of the city
so we're we're like right next to nature
as well so some of the cockroaches we
find
are pretty massive right and at this
point
i was living in thailand with sydney and
it was just me and sydney in the house
right
and so i was just sitting in my living
room just chilling out
and i hear this [ __ ] guttural scream
coming from sydney right
she's like i had never heard sydney like
sydney's already a loud person as is
but i had no no no but i had never heard
this kind of scream from sydney i was
just like
i thought she just witnessed the [ __ ]
murder or something right that's the
kind of
yeah so i come rushing over thinking
that something serious something bad has
happened
and i just see this [ __ ] massive
cockroach just
chilling in our kitchen but yeah how big
are we talking okay
so it was about it was about that big
okay it was it was a chunky [ __ ]
how much bigger does it need to get
brushed that's [ __ ] talking
that's the point it was terraforming
yeah yeah yeah because because the way
the cockroaches get in because our
kitchen is pretty clean but because
we're right on the outskirts right
near the forest and everything so
sometimes they can like crawl up the
drains
and like come out from other come out
from under the trees i didn't know this
i only found out
about this afterwards because my first
thought was [ __ ] i thought our kitchen
is clean [ __ ]
burned the entire house down and
everything right but this was my first
time playing stealth
and like i don't know how you guys are
with bugs i'm sure you'll find joey
because you're australian
like for me i'm not i'm not like a
massive fan of bugs you know
i like i don't enjoy i mean i mean i'm
not a fan yeah
i'm not a fan of having to deal with
them but some people can just like
[ __ ] grab the bugs or whatever i'm
just like
no i'll do like the cup method where you
know you see a spider you like cup it
and uh put a piece of paper in it and
just let it out i don't enjoy it
i'm not i'm not like i'm not like scared
but i'm not i don't enjoy
doing it it's not a fun process it's not
a fun process
you know when there's people who like
[ __ ] grab the spiders and are like
oh what do you mean you're scared i
don't want to [ __ ] grab the spider
why would i want to grab this one
even if even if i don't like hate this
thing yeah why the [ __ ] would i want to
have it wriggling around in my hand
exactly why are you doing the aussies
the method that my dad uses to get rid
of we'll do that afterwards
sucks in his mouth son
but yeah because because because me and
cindy are a couple
because she's like i i feel like when
you're in a couple
the one who's least scared is the one
that deals with the power of course of
course and of course
it was me i wasn't happy about it but i
was just like sydney you're you just you
you
you look like you just witnessed like a
murder whatever get out of the way
i guess as the man i guess i guess as
the man of the house here
i will take care of the cockroach i know
i have to do it
and i was thinking this was going to be
easy right the cockroach was big you
know
and i didn't know that much about
cockroaches at the time
so yeah oh how nice how naive i was so i
thought
this is going to be an easy because we
had like literally we had a cockroach
spray
and i was thinking all i need to do is
get the spray
spray the cockroach job done it dies i
sweep it out the house
yeah easy right now so i get the spray
and there are there are two pieces of
information
that i didn't know about cockroaches
before i did this
number one cockroaches are very very
hard to kill
and i knew this but i thought it's a
spray designed to kill cockroaches
therefore in my mind instant death you
know that's that's how it's worked my
entire life
right number two cockroaches can fly
yeah i did not know this either some
species are all of them
i think all of them can fly i've never
seen a cockroach fly i mean they gotta
they have to be pretty [ __ ]
like yeah gtfo modes yeah yeah
so so i did not know that they could fly
either so it was just like crawling
around the floor
like terraforming oh yeah it's literally
totally it's like literally the last
resort for these cocktails so i'm just
like sydney get out of the way
let the man of the house handle this and
so i get the spray out
get pretty close to it and i just give
it a nice little love tap of a spray
and what happens it starts freaking the
[ __ ] out right yeah i'm just like
what the [ __ ] is happening right and
then i spray even more
and then i just hear that
[Music]
you know the sound where you just hear
the wings flapping and then it starts
flapping
and then it flies and lands on my chest
and then i counter attack and then i'm
in [ __ ] flight or fight or flight
mode now
i uh and then i [ __ ] scream as loud
as i've like screamed in my life before
i think i
i i'm not ashamed to admit how [ __ ]
loud i screamed five minutes after i've
just told sydney
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] let me handle
this
i brush it off like i [ __ ] leg it out
of the kitchen
and i just like locked the kitchen right
and i could hear
i could hear like the cockroach just
like freaking out in the kitchen here
it's just like
[Music]
you like
did you do it what's what's going on and
i'm just like
just don't go in that kitchen and like
me and sydney were just like
we were just like we were just like in
the living room we could just hear this
cockroach for the entire night just
freaking out and we were just like
oh god are we gonna have to burn the
entire house down it'll get bored
yeah he'll get it it'll get bored
eventually cockroach spray is the
biggest [ __ ] lie
on the planet i feel like aren't
cockroaches the only animals that can
like survive a nuclear blast
i don't know something like that so it's
like what is in these sprays
that is supposedly stronger than a
nuclear blast
that's why i like i don't stop until it
stops moving i'm like i'm like
you know apex aim yeah i i'm
following it around the room yeah i
thought that would be fine as well like
i said i didn't know they could fly that
was the big
oh they could fly this is the rules of
the game have changed now they can
counter-attack you now
normally i spray them just so that
they're stunned for a second so i can
[ __ ] smack him
yeah uh well i mean i don't i don't like
doing that because then it leaves like a
mark
yeah yeah and also it's not a guaranteed
kill unless you're using
unless you're using like a [ __ ] heavy
helicopter joe joe what's your kda with
cockroaches
yeah you grab like a suit a sushi right
because the sole of the suit shoes are
very firm
very flat you can just like [ __ ] clap
them on there oh yeah that's true yeah
i mean the way my dad is a weird
conversation even hardcore all right so
i'm not [ __ ] eating yeah he's just
australian it's freezing so
i've so we know in our household we
already
know cockroach spray is a lie so just
don't even use the spirit yeah it's like
cockroach sprays are a lie it yeah it
does it never kills the cockroach
yeah just smack them with the spray yeah
like no or you do what my dad does which
is
in australia because we also have like
big fuck-off cockroaches like that
yeah all right and there was one that
appeared in the kitchen what it's always
the kitchen
they appeared in the kitchen my mom
screams my dad walks in and is like what
is it
he points to the wall and there's a big
[ __ ] off cockroach like that
he's like son peter
he calls me over yes father what is it
it's like son
bring me two tissues and i was like
a bigger pun it's like bring me two
tissues one ply
i want a few just two like just two all
right
i bring him two tissues and he's like
place it on my hand
i place a flat on his hand one on top of
the other and he's like he dead ass
looks at me and he goes
watch this he goes up to the wall
and i've never seen a man move this fast
in my life he was like and he just grabs
him
and it's in his hand like in a blink of
an eye
he's just [ __ ] it just grabs it in
his hand and you can hear this thing
just
like around in his hand and then he
works
no he walks up to my mom and goes right
up to her ear and goes
crunchy
and he looks me in the eyes and he's
like i love that sound
i'm like you you're the most australian
father i could ever have and i love it
it's just like the weirdest [ __ ]
house on earth yeah i think i was like
eight years old when he did that and i
was like my dad is the strongest in the
world
that was the moment don't [ __ ] like
how
that's how to assert dominance in your
family right you're introducing the
anime video yeah
like no you know like if you're in the
playground you make in front of each
other's dads or you know like trying to
one-up each other's dads don't say oh no
my dad's the president of nintendo no my
dad
grabs cockroaches by hand and crushes
them today my dad can beat up with your
dad well
my dad like [ __ ] hand grunts pockets
it's [ __ ] like some kung fu movie
right away she's like you know you know
i've i've never seen because i thought i
was like is this guy really gonna
catch this cockroach by hand because
like yeah we all know how fast
you're surprised
but i feel like my dad is like i don't
know
when it comes to like insects for some
reason he's like weirdly really
like lucky i guess or i don't know what
the right word for lucky
okay he told me this story of one time
he was
like out on the backyard and he was with
his brother my uncle
and obviously if you're you know
barbecuing out in the summer or whatever
in australia
there's a [ __ ] a lot of flies everywhere
right right but you just you know
[ __ ] brush them off it's whatever
and uh my dad was like he was like i
don't know teenager or something
and he had a knife in his hand just like
a regular like steak knife right
and just kind of like had it in his hand
and he saw a fly on the table
and he just went and he cut the
fly's head cleanly in half
and he just kind of stood there it was
like the psychopath i can't believe i
just did
that that's that's like some [ __ ] men
[ __ ] yeah
like that's like what's the anime move
where you can like
completely remove your presents right
because you know this dad is dead
she appeared right behind me i didn't
notice him because like i have never
successfully like
like caught or swatted like a house fly
in my life have you ever like
successfully like
smacked a mosquito in your head no uh
mosquito yeah
mosquitoes like they're like annoying
but it's it's doable
fly it's like they they they have like
observation haki you know they
they know what's coming five seconds
before it comes you know it's like a
[ __ ] it's like goku vs frieza it's just
like
teleporting or avoid bullets
or something because the way that they
like flies yeah when the like is when
you
like something goes near them like the
air pressure they like use it to like
get away
oh really like dodge yeah it's really
interesting i don't know i've never
showered
i swear i saw a youtube video of someone
shooting a fly with it how can you
[ __ ] shoot
a fly isn't like a massive target anyway
best marksman versus best fly youtube
marksman versus fly yeah i i guess i
mean it sounds like a scene from an
anime
youtube recommended i'm like did i
actually watch that or did i make it
remember a bunch of facts yeah and
stories
like this one time where this guy did
the thing but i don't really know i
don't really know
he did a thing and it was impressive i
don't know something about a cube you
know
something about a cube or something wait
so wait what is the what is the worst
furniture i'm saying
beds are terrible i know we're going way
back yeah we're going we're going way
back you never finished it but uh
okay yeah beds are terrible yeah but i
think coffee tables
somehow these small things can sometimes
be the worst [ __ ] things on earth
they're like let's make coffee tables
like the most secure thing ever in
existence out of all the things i've
built
so for the past week i've built chairs
i've built coffee tables
cabinets you know all that kind of [ __ ]
the worst one by far was the ikea chairs
and they're like it's like four pieces
and they just over complicate the [ __ ]
out of it
for no reason yeah actually the worst
one i built were
my table and chair set and that's
because when i built it
um follow the exact instructions and you
think you screw it tight
oh it'll it'll it'll just work perfectly
it's a chair
yeah right and literally every chair
[ __ ] wobbled
right it was just uneven yeah and i i
spent
i spent an entire day having to like
perfectly unscrew these
like screws so that the chairs were like
balanced and i'm just like why can't you
just balance it normally it's a chair
it's literally it should just be same
length
all four chairs no it's it wasn't the
case that's why that's why it was a
[ __ ] nightmare for me that's just
like a dick move on the design
right that was just like i'm a [ __ ] with
this guy the next guy who buys my chair
yeah but like yeah i was like i i i also
agree with you about the bed i didn't
i didn't want to build my bed so much
that
i just never go to bed wait what are you
sleeping on i
i sleep on a mattress yeah just a
mattress what do you actually
wait wait so you don't have a bed frame
at home now
i i actually because because i i
actually like it right because
you can get those like you can it's so
ghetto you can get the [ __ ] uh the
low frames yeah the ones that are like
literally on the floor
isn't it also like really bad for your
floor to just have like a mattress on it
is that
doesn't it get like moldy or whatever i
did the whole reason if you looked
underneath your mattress isn't that the
whole reason for a bed frame just to
stop like the floor from molding or
something no no no what if you google
this
we do have like a bed frame but it's
like one of those literally
floor bread bed frames where it's like
you can put it just a plank of wood on
yeah so
it's basically just a plank of wood you
can get the the floor bed yeah
and the reason for it was because we we
when we moved in uh
we just like slept on a futon at corners
for like a week and at first sydney was
just like why would why would we sleep
on the floor peasants sleep on the floor
and me
being the asian like i every time i go
like to thailand i'd always sleep on the
floor at my grandma's place and i'm just
like
there's something comforting about
sleeping on the floor and i don't know
what it is but
i sleep i i just realized that whenever
we'd go to like onsens or ryokans or
whatever you'd sleep on the futon floors
fusion mattresses
and you just get the best night of sleep
you have in your life and i don't know
what it is i think it might be because
like the tatami or the floor or whatever
it is you're you're sleeping on the
hard surface it like flattens your back
out yeah so i guess that just like
naturally gives you better sleepers
yeah but i agree like i don't know i get
the best sleep in a futon yeah so like
we just we just we just decided why not
just [ __ ] sleep on the floor like we
just we just got to match
then you miss out on like the you know
when you wake up and you're like oh [ __ ]
then you just kind of like sit on the
bed with like your legs
on the floor yeah you're just like [ __ ]
i gotta get up but like you're not
feeling like do you love that feeling
i kind of like that i hate that because
i don't want to get out of bed right
away
but i want to kind of get up and i want
to put my you know i want to try to get
ready i'll hype myself up
for me there's only two states there's
lying in the bed
on my phone or just out of bed yeah well
you never you never like sit there at
this edge of the bed
being like like [ __ ] i gotta get
happiness no like i i kind of realized
that i i i want to spend the least time
in my bedroom as
physically possible right and i feel
like you get a better night's sleep if
like your bedroom is
just for sleeping because they're like i
remember in my old place especially when
like we saw i started youtube and we
were working literally with my bed next
to me
yeah i would get like the worst night's
sleep every time because i could not
like
i could not go in my bedroom and just
you know go on my bed and just like go
into sleep mode
like i found that once i
positioned it so i would spend the least
time on my bed as possible
i would get much better sleep yeah my my
place two places ago now
was yeah it was the same like you guys
you guys been there before the tiny
apartment i had the [ __ ] tiny
tiny apartment the anime man couch with
all the plushies well
when i was like 18 i probably would have
thought that was a cool ass apartment
no when i first moved in it was a cool
awesome yeah when you get older you're
like ah
but then i very quickly realized that if
you're where you work
is in the same room or next to where you
sleep
yeah you get the worst sleep yeah you
get the worst productive like
the worst productivity you just can't do
anything because it's like i could just
turn over and literally walk half a
meter and just sleep
if i wanted to yeah it's like how can
you concentrate in a room like that
yeah i don't know i feel like
there was parts where i enjoyed it like
i liked the fact that i could just kind
of like
turn my monitor towards my bed and i
could just watch it because sometimes
watching stuff on the tv
it's real pain in the ass cause like you
know
on pc you can just get the website up
and then you can throw it on the monitor
right that's easy on a tv you got to
[ __ ] around with like all the chromecast
[ __ ] you got to figure out
which apps work for my tv which don't
you know the pc it's like whatever i
mean it's not
it's not that much yeah it's like five
more minutes worth of work that i don't
want
and also i used to have a set up that i
really liked where i had like uh i had
like a
next to my bed i had a keyboard with
like a track pad on it
right so i would just like [ __ ] light
a [ __ ] in my bed
and then like change the that's how
people get bedridden
i think i was like getting there i was
trial running yeah
yeah yeah i mean you know if i wasn't a
bed ridden at least i know the system
like i had
i was like yeah i do i had it all set up
you know it was a good system it was big
big price yeah but like i feel like
especially
when i get out of bed i'm just like way
more awake
probably the problem isn't like
typically when i'm out of my bed i'm
awake yeah yeah the problem the problem
is the problem isn't that the problem is
getting out of the bed in the first
place like
having having my legs hang off whatever
that's not going to help me
yeah sometimes the the foot out of the
bed free hanging is
pretty pretty good feeling though i
still haven't figured out i still
haven't figured out a way to get out of
bed when it's like a cold winter's day
or cold winter yeah yeah that's why i
like i'm kind of glad
now that i moved like because you know
it's starting to get warm
right yeah so it's like thank god a lot
it's a lot easier now to just
immediately get out of bed because the
inside of your mattress and
the outside of your mattress is pretty
much the same temperature yeah so it's
like it's not a [ __ ] struggle like it
is in the winter
but yeah i know i to this day i've been
trying to figure out
how the [ __ ] do i get out of bed in
winter how do i like remove the 10 g's
of force that is created
in the wintertime in my bed because it
yeah because every time
i i always do like the the one thing i
found out is like okay one limit at a
time
yeah it's like stick one arm out get
that like to room temperature
right all right and then get the next
limb out and then it's just like a slow
like processor it's like slow loading
it's it's like you know when you're like
going into the swimming pool for the
first time it's like a really cold pool
is it like do you jump in straight away
would you go one limb at a time
i jump in straight away because that's
that's how i feel whenever i need to get
out of bed on a cold winter's night he
was like
you just gotta like chug a [ __ ] ton of
water when you wake up that [ __ ] wakes
you up
yeah just get a full bottle of water
when you wake up just down but i can
chug a full bowl of water
in bed and then there is no way
you can lie back down after chugging a
full bottle of water 100
what is that what does that work this
episode is sponsored by expressvpn a few
decades ago private citizens used to be
largely that
private what changed the internet think
about everything you've browsed searched
for watched or tweeted now imagine all
that data being crawled through
collected and aggregated by third
parties into a permanent public record
your record having your private life
exposed for others to see was once
something only celebrities worried about
but in an era where everyone is online
everyone is a public figure to keep my
data private when i go online i turn to
expressvpn did you know there are
hundreds of data brokers out there who
sold businesses to buy and sell your
data
the worst part is they don't have to
tell you who they're selling it to or
get your consent
no consent in 2021 one of these data
points is your ip address
data harvesters use your ip to uniquely
identify you
and your location but you know what with
expressvpn
my connection gets rerouted through an
encrypted server and my ip
is masked every time i turn express vpn
on i'm given a random ip address shared
by other expressvpn customers that makes
it more difficult for third parties to
identify me and harvest my data and the
best part is is how easy xpressvpn is to
use no matter what device you're on
phone laptop or smart tv all you have to
do is tap one button to get protected so
if
like me you believe that your data is
your business secure yourself with the
number one rate of vpn
on the market visit expressvpn.comtaste
and get three extra months for
free that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
trash taste go to expressvpn.com trash
taste to learn more
that's the episode baby listen i don't
understand the rules of hydration gone
all i know is that
semi waterboarding your organs wakes you
up
what's
you know my organs are sleeping and it's
like oh god we're drowning oh jesus
wakes up and you're also hydrated
so it's a win-win no no i i do that the
first thing i do when i get out is like
take a piss and then drink a shitload of
water i mean i drink enough [ __ ]
water as it is i hate morning peas man
morning peas suck because it's it's
always like [ __ ] really
strong too because you're dehydrated
always frothing as [ __ ]
you you've been holding it in all night
you know what i mean
so you wake up and you're like oh i
really need to piss but i'm also like i
really want to stay in bed yeah and then
the only most the time if i don't chug
the water the thing that gets me up is
the
the uncomfort of needing to piss is
stronger than my want to stay in this
bed
yeah yeah it's it i think it hurts it
gets it's like in a blind demand
it's like it's like doing your first
lift in the gym right it always hurts
right like the bladder is like the
bladder is like i haven't done anything
all day
it's like that no because your bladder
hasn't been moving all night and then
suddenly it has to move so it's like all
right [ __ ] let's do it
ah i know i i always like i always like
mine
always just like comes out easily but i
think that's just because i drink a [ __ ]
ton of water before i go to bed
how do you not get up do you get up in
the middle of the night to pee i just
find
that the time it takes for the water to
get in is the perfect amount of time
for me to sleep so it's just like
optimal it's just like it's just like
natural
like it's just a natural alarm clock i
feel like in the past two years i i
before two years ago i never ever woke
up to pee
ever yeah and then suddenly now it's
like genuinely i have to like [ __ ]
like precise like precisely time
when i drink water now otherwise i'm
going to wake up like six a.m
i almost that's the thing i almost never
drink water before i go to bed or never
drink anything
go to bed this is an angel sort of like
you're 24 months
what are you
i turned like 24 like the the clock
ticked over and i was like
[ __ ] my body's falling apart my life is
going to [ __ ] like
losing my hair i'm pissing everywhere my
bladder hurts all the time you know it's
like what's going on like
i can't catch a [ __ ] break when did
my body start doing this i just never
happened before
i have really vivid memories totally
about tangent about peeing now
okay well for some reason when i watched
wild wild west for the first time
at 12 years old i for some reason i was
so
so proud of myself as like an
eight-year-old kid that i'd managed to
sit through a whole movie
without peeing i mean yeah i i
would be proud as well i still can't do
that when you're a kid we did you piss
all the time
yes i mean you know me i still piss all
the time so is this like
me like piss machine 2000
that you know when you're a kid you have
to pee a lot and then you know you pee
less and then when you get to like mid
twenties it's like you're good
no i paid just as much as i did when i
was like i i think you're just getting
onto
like our level now of like how much you
pee yeah i mean i'm not fond of this
yeah i mean i i drink like a lot of
water i mean just
look at that look at this glass believe
it or not this is a full glass of water
that i've just tried
like the amount you could scarcely
camera moments on trash taste where i'm
just like talking and then it's my glass
is just empty and i have to like
i go through talking about your weird
like side mouth drinking [ __ ]
i'm not talking about that it's just
can i hear an explanation about that why
do you do i have no i
did not even know i didn't i got you i
get it sometimes
drinking water is boring you gotta spice
it up a little bit
i no no you've done this you've done
this one you've just drank water in a
funny way because you're like you're
bored yeah when i was like 10.
no i showed you gosh and then i realized
oh i should probably just drink it
however
thank you very much for the refill
mailing yes i did i did need to stay
hydrated yeah i don't know i just like
sometimes you slurp excessively you know
to like aerate the water you know
all the flavors come out well
what are you talking about
[Laughter]
when you're a kid you're like the dog's
doing it clearly yeah i watched my cat
dog
i was like whoa i stupid dog just drink
it yeah
just pick it up and then you try it and
you're like this is wildly inefficient
this really feels like there could have
been a better way of the dog one of
those [ __ ] been at this bowl
for like five minutes
are you telling me over thousands of
years of evolution the dog couldn't slur
a little bit i couldn't just like parker
these dogs have like near [ __ ] echo
location and you're telling me they
couldn't develop a slurp
like i could learn that [ __ ] with a
youtube guide in 20 minutes right
now are you just kidding me how to slow
wookie hat works
out oh my gosh i don't know don't be a
dog
how do we get onto this i don't know
point is stay hydrated weebs it's uh
it's healthy for you right i mean yeah
it is
it is i mean yeah i don't know like i've
always just drunk a [ __ ] ton of water
ever since i was a kid
um which is why i think while like one
of my biggest
like one of my biggest habits i feel
that have allowed me to stay thin is
that i just don't really like soda that
much
it's just i'd rather drink i okay here's
the thing i
hate i hate soda when it's like at full
fizziness
right what the [ __ ] are you talking
about okay okay okay
we're going we're going off tangent i i
only thought please please i really
thought of this because tangent the
episode
this is tangent the episode i only
thought about this because i saw like
another like
hot take sydney tweet last night oh that
one which was which was
like uh i i can't remember exactly what
it was like
yeah that soda is better than that i
turned off my computer after i saw that
i was like you can't be serious
and i'm just like i don't agree with
that but i half
agree with that because i cannot for the
life of me just like
fully enjoy fully fizzy soda like for me
peak soda
right i cannot drink soda with sodas
when you sleep on the floor
just start [ __ ] welcome to another
garn hot food take
okay pig soda for me is soda with ice
right because you have to like you pour
it on the ice
water downstairs yeah yeah yeah yeah i
do like a little bit watered down soda
because like
for me like coke over can it's so fizzy
that you just can't i don't understand
how it is
it is it's just throat made out of
people like that
oh it hurts it's fine it's just [ __ ]
gassy as [ __ ] like
soda a drink is meant to be refreshing
tell me you can't tell me after you
down like a fully fizzy soda it doesn't
have to be cooked just any any soda
because i don't drink coke anymore
either yeah but like after you like open
it just
hear that like sound you drink it down
and then you do that
massive [ __ ] the book was very good
it's like the best [ __ ] feeling of
you know normally i'm always willing to
try and understand your point guard but
i
i honestly i don't even know where this
is coming from like this is weird this
is this is coming from
i've never drank a soda in like damn i
wish this was less carbonated
because like to me a drink is meant to
be refreshing right yeah
i just that's that's why that's why
we're drinking carbonation it's meant to
be the
combination is supposed to be refreshing
the carbonation is not refreshing it's
pretty refreshing
it's not refreshing well i can tell you
this sugared out flat a soda is
definitely not refreshing
i don't like flat soda i do not like
flat stove flat soda is awful
right it's just when it's like on ice
you get like you get a bit of the fizz
out and that's like the perfect amount
of carbonation in a soda
that's that's why if if i drink soda if
i want to
if i want it to be refreshing it needs a
little bit of ice just to get a bit of
that carbonation out
perfect too long
who taught you this this man wants to
hydrate no matter what
it just it's i mean like soda doesn't
have water in it then
yeah i mean like a fully carbonated soda
i feel like i'm losing hydration by
drinking that i don't know why
okay fair the only i don't drink soda
anymore either i haven't really drank
soda in like maybe a couple years i mean
every now and then if there's like a
drink bar or whatever
years sometimes okay no like okay i've i
haven't dead ass i haven't like bought
like
a bottle of coke or like right or
anything like that in a couple of years
you know it's not when i order at
mcdonald's i have to you know you can no
i always get tea at mcdonald's i used to
get milk but then i just felt like a
child
milk milk at mcdonald's and the milk
carton would turn up
at my you got to get uber eats you know
and you'd have to order i didn't even
know you get milk in mcdonald's you can
get milk in it and the cotton would turn
up and
the guy will you know the ubud scout the
milkman right look
at me like seriously seriously
because i don't know if this is like a
tactical thing to get us to drink more
coke but they just stopped putting like
water in the package deals and i was
really offended by that because i'm like
it's literally from a tap
like well why are you offended just go
to your top well i just
you know sometimes i you know i want to
get the the value of a meal
like the deal but i sometimes i want to
support a multi-billion dollar
corporation
i want to feel like i've gotten back a
little bit i want to save a little bit
of money on this
this rip-off you know you know because i
really like the mcdonald's fries
so i want the fries with the burger and
i mean you have to get a drink then i
don't really know what i want
milk i don't want i don't want milk
either just sat there in my fridge and i
would like i'd stamped it in a cotton
squeezed it into my tea
like really depressingly you can get
milk at mcdonald's
yeah are you lagging
i was just agreeing and then i was just
like wait that doesn't that doesn't
compute in my mind
kids kids want to drink milk it's it's
it's like the golden arches m for milk
i have never seen milk at mcdonald's
milk i do
because like i know you can get water
it's not like on the [ __ ] front shop
they're like look check out our milk
it's like
you have milk i know you can get like
juice boxes i know you can get like
bottled water i've never seen anyone get
milk before just because no one [ __ ]
had no [ __ ] orders the [ __ ] the
expiration date on this thing must have
been like 10 years past they said they
i'm pretty sure they [ __ ] dusted it
off before they put it in my [ __ ]
ubereats
just yogurt at that point
probably what they're putting into the
mcflurries i didn't [ __ ] carve it out
it was like butter when i got it
[ __ ] it was so funny well the [ __ ]
milkshakes on the milkshake machines are
never working right
have enough milk this [ __ ] keeps
buying our milk
we need it for the milkshake machine
look how i feel whenever i [ __ ] t
from starbucks i'm like i feel like i'm
doing something wrong
oh i've i didn't even know you could do
that yeah
oh you can buy tsr bucks who buys tea at
starbucks
some of them are okay actually but i i
used to feel like now it's a bit more i
feel like t
has become more mainstream and like i
feel like
it's a fashion statement i feel like 10
years ago coffee was like the thing it
was like everyone just
this is a weird thing but in starbucks
it was all about coffee coffee coffee
now it's all like everyone's chilled out
you can get you can order a [ __ ] tea
no one gives a [ __ ] now
this is a weird statement i don't feel
like i i don't know sometimes i make a
point and i know this is going to be a
really hard battle
to not look weird i just i just went
through that five minutes ago
it's more like i don't go to starbucks
enough to
be like oh there's a new trend coming in
here ladies and gentlemen it's tea
now no i just i just remember that like
i feel like i got mocked when i ordered
tea one time at a starbucks
what by who uh by my maybe my
classmates when i was like 15 i ordered
a tea and they were like
at starbucks men drink coffee connor
yeah yeah
no because like i i feel like it's more
back then would you
why would you go to starbucks for
anything but a coffee or coffee yeah
you didn't feel like i feel like that's
what it was back then and now everyone
doesn't really give a [ __ ] you can get
what you want
i mean i i would feel in england
especially you get a t you get a c
[ __ ] anyway it's [ __ ] england
everyone
every one of their drinks i think that's
what it is it's more like you could get
a tea anywhere so why did you get it
yeah but you know back back when i
worked at the bbc
okay here it is
but uh yeah back when i worked in the
office you know everyone would uh
every so often like the newbies or like
the interns or the graduates
they were always on t duty and i was
like that one person
in my entire team of like 20. i'm just
like
uh actually can i get a coffee please
like
literally everyone in everyone around me
drank tea ever that's that's what
everyone drinks
and all the interns scoffed at
coffee coffee what's that what we're in
england team the uk is weird because
like
i think most rituals don't even drink
any other
type than english breakfast tea yeah
like i think most people
from the uk if you ask them i want a cup
of tea they would not ever even consider
anything else
other than like they don't specify the
type of tea well it's a thing in the uk
if you ask for a cup of tea you're
getting distracted just a
pg i didn't even know it was called
english breakfast i i yeah i i
just knew it was it's yeah yeah we have
brands right so we have friends in the
uk when you say i want a tea you get
the same type of tea yeah right right
unless you specify
all right dude if you if you sit there
in someone's house and you're like oh i
want a tea and they're like oh do you
have like green tea or like some chai
they'd be like
no no that's exactly yeah really
yeah yeah yeah weird so if i came into
your house in the uk and i said
uh no no no because if you want a
different kind of tea you have to
specify yeah but
most houses i don't think most houses
have other types of so i went into a
house and just said i can have some
chamomile tea
i feel like those types of teas are like
almost like luxury teas in the uk yeah
because
they always come in like fancy packaging
because like the british type is like it
comes in like
500 pack because that'll last you one
month in the uk yeah yeah
like if you've got a family as well like
that yeah everyone in your family is
drinking tea so this is like when
americans ask me that what kind of tea
drinking connor it's like well
it's like i have a tea and then i have
like a an afternoon tea which i drink
you know you drink like you try
everything you try the old greys you try
the other types
but if i'm drinking tea i have english
breakfast in the morning no
no no all day all day all day but it's
called english breakfast it's all day
yeah but it's it's you people just drink
it as like
like they drink coffee it's it's it's
like a yeah but you don't call it
morning coffee
no no it's like old gray or whatever
it's like
the type of the t-shirt part of british
culture you know you need to chill out
you just chill out with a cup
but i realized how strange it was when
going to america it's like that's not at
all how it is no
it's like americans don't drink tea
anyway i think they actually they kind
of
i think they do but again like if you
order these other people yeah if you
ordered
you know how i know americans don't
drink tea why because have you seen
their [ __ ] kettles that's true that's
true like like
no no culture that drinks tea is built
around the [ __ ] kettles that the
americans use like
what kind of kettles no americans oh
it's just these terrible things are
these awful things that can hold like
maybe 500 mils not even enough cups for
two people
yeah you can you got to put it on the
stove right oh those ones you put it on
the stove
and as a brit i'm like [ __ ] the heat
efficiency of this is giving me clinical
depression
what the [ __ ] is this i'm just like you
know you know
when i go to someone's house in the uk
and they start doing that [ __ ] i'm not
going to do it what are you doing come
on
like that's no no no i'll i'll i'll tell
you the one thing that gave me a [ __ ]
brain aneurysm as someone who doesn't
even drink tea right
so huh i i drink i'm mostly a coffee
drinker
i'm i'm i'm most i'm mostly a coffee i'm
mostly a coffee drinker let me tell you
about tea
this thing i don't know about the thing
i don't i don't i don't drink
english breakfast tea a lot of times i i
i drink green tea fancy [ __ ]
wow i mean
i'd say the amount of tea selection in
asia just [ __ ] eclipses whatever we
have in england i mean come on
we have that tea you just you just don't
order it you have to go
you have to go to the store manager be
like can you can you unlock the safe
was the other variation
you have to like move all the other tees
in the aisle to the back so you can
grab these things yeah exactly i mean
you go to if you go to a [ __ ] company
it's like opening pandora's boxes of tea
you know you got you got an entire
[ __ ] selection and in england you got
like where you got like lip to nice tea
that's pretty that's i don't even count
that as a [ __ ] team but to be fair in
the combini
in japan it is like here's the 59th
version of green tea
and it's like you literally can't make i
don't even actually think it's
chemically possible to do 59 variations
of green tea
how much molecular like division are we
doing today this these bombs here
it's just like leaves they picked from
like the 59th flight field yeah
it's absurd like and all the half of
them takes the sh the [ __ ] say it
doesn't matter okay
like this t which is like i don't even
know what the [ __ ] this is yeah
you could live in japan for five years
and try trying new tea different days
i've tried most of them yeah you've
tried every japanese tea right
i could confirm that half of them taste
exactly the [ __ ]
yeah and there was also like uh you know
in japan they had like
uh low low fat green teas or healthy
green teas and i'm like green tea is
healthy what do you mean
like it's probably one of the things
it's like does greece have calories
no no it doesn't no it doesn't but
there's like healthier low calorie
creams well it was like there was like
[ __ ] that was like that was like
negative calories
it was like good health green tea and
i'm like green tea is i actually think
one of the healthiest teas of all the
tea yeah it is
so what do you mean like what have they
done to the other teas guys
i can do one better i got an idea zero
calorie
water
by drinking it you lose calories yeah
but
yeah i just going about the whole thing
i just get very amazed that like you
know
because americans always asking people
from other countries like what tea do
you drink you know i drink
they're like oh i drink it early i drink
this it's like i don't know in the uk
it's not like that at all
like that's not how it works are you
sure that's just not like your household
no no that's it's all of the uk you go
anywhere you want a cup of tea you get
it like
yeah no matter where you're going it's
only in the uk where if you say tea
it means one type of tea right and i
just always thought that's tea that's
just yeah yeah
every other tea is just like the branded
tea right i guess it's the same in japan
as well like if you go to
someone's household and you ask for ocha
which is tea yeah
you usually get greedy that's like the
default skin in there yeah japan
it's also weird like the lengths that
british people would go to to bring
tea with them or like have a cup of tea
available
like i remember like uh you know when we
went whenever you go like camping on an
expedition i remember there was a guy
when we did like duke of edinburgh
who he like he drove
uh a car around to keep up with us but
in this thing there was just a whole
like massive hot water tank just for tea
so that we could all have tea okay you
know and i didn't think of that as weird
yeah yeah so we could all have a cup of
tea when we were done yeah
because that's the british people that's
how you signify that working
yeah yeah like whenever we went
paintballing in the uk or anything like
that
during the break you'd get tea yeah
would be that you read like [ __ ]
warfare and it'd be like stop chaps time
for the t-birds
you go for a tea break and now that i
think about this out loud weird but i'm
like yeah we
go to like no matter what you're doing
in the uk someone is going to try and
put a cup of tea available yeah
the stereotype is totally true it is it
is totally true like the best analogy i
can think of
is that to britain's to brits a cup of
tea is like the equivalent to like a
cigarette break
right it's just it's just an excuse to
like put on the kettle
like yeah like drink a bunch of tea and
just chill out for like five minutes
we have those in australia we don't know
we don't have tea breaks we have smokers
yeah getting back getting back to why i
know like americans don't drink tea
right
yeah okay one kettle's a [ __ ] two like
okay so
i remember i was staying with sydney and
so
uh she had like a little bit of or
someone had a sore throat right so we
just needed some warm water
right and so how would you make warm
water right
boil in a can boiling water and then put
you know put the hot water in and just
fill it with cold water
so sydney takes the mug
and goes up fills it up with water
puts in the microwave
it in the microwave and puts on a
counter and i'm just like
what are you doing sydney i feel like
i'm getting a brain aneurysm just
watching this right now that's horrible
and i was just like there's no way
there's no there's no way this is normal
there's no way this is [ __ ] normal
and so she says no it's it's a normal
thing here
and i'm just like bet and i tweet i'm
just like
americans is this a normal thing to do
and the amount of like
what's wrong how do you heat up your
water
like i'm just like how is this
how have we gone through like thousands
of years of civilization
to heat up water in a microwave i'm
gonna do my my
obligatory in salt america mark that off
the bingo check this out
americans literally think that the
microwave is like
a tool from god yeah you can do
everything do everything
[ __ ] i've looked the kitchen nightmares
just taught me that thank you
it's totally reality obviously
i don't know you know i recently i i
abandoned
my kettle in japan i got rid of it
really it was you know
british cattle's a lot intense like also
i you know i i i when i when we boil
kettles in the uk it's down in what like
one minute
yeah two minutes max yeah that's a
that's a [ __ ] cattle if it's any longer
than that yeah
and you won't get even the shittiest of
cattles don't
like the worst kettles you find are in
hotels that like you put the water in
you come back 40 minutes later shit's
still boiling making like
the world's loudest sound somehow it's
like
it's like how is this the shittest cat
this is a change surely you could have
got a deal from the manufacturer to get
a
not [ __ ] capital half the water's
evaporated by the time yeah it's gone by
the time you [ __ ] but you get [ __ ]
200 milliliters of water it's like not
even fills up the cup
it's absolutely abysmal it's like pretty
but like wasted half the [ __ ] hotels
electricity as well
it's [ __ ] dreadful but in japan as
well as they have the same thing and
america is the same the kettles take
so goddamn long to boil and they're so
[ __ ] i got so tired of it because i'm
streaming
between games yeah i don't want to be
waiting for like five minutes
yeah exactly i'm streaming i can't i
can't sit there and wait so i i
i found like japan has these things that
i've again i've never seen these before
but
they're just like uh they have them in
conbinis where it's like this a boiling
water jug
oh i know i know but you can fill the
ramen yeah oh yes
the ones where you like can pour it
right yeah
it's like a two liter jug or whatever
yeah you fill it up with water
and then it boils it or it doesn't boil
it puts it like you can choose the
temperature yeah yeah
and it's just i mean it's just always
hot it's always hard yeah yeah and i
think it uses
less less electricity than constantly
reboiling a category yeah
yeah um and uh yeah i felt so big brain
because now
you know when i i just have hot water
ready right literally i can just go to
the thing
put the bag in boom hot water i'm like
sure because because that's
because that's what every asian uses for
like cut ramen yeah that's that's the
cup ramen machine and tea
machine yeah and then i'm like [ __ ]
maybe maybe kettles are
obsolete this is the way good buy
kettles
i i was kind of like [ __ ] i've kettle
has been like the first appliance i buy
i never thought about it like that
because i've seen that all the time in
asia because that's that's
just readily available whenever i'd come
to thailand holy [ __ ] yeah that's true
that's true that is more efficient
it's so much more efficient and you
literally have it ready but anything's
better than a [ __ ] microwave okay
please don't do that [ __ ] stop it get
help
so in a it's called sixth form in the uk
i've got what's called america
we there was a guy and we had like uh we
had a microwave and a kettle in our
you know like dorm room or like chill
room it's for like the yeah you got two
years left
and uh this guy was like you want a cup
of tea i was like yeah i'll have a cup
of tea
you won't believe this man he puts water
in the cup puts the tea bag in and puts
in the microwave oh
my i'm about to [ __ ] i'm about to
[ __ ] leave right now the entire team
like like he pours the water cold into
the the cup with the tea bag
cold lets it like stew and puts it in
the microwave and heats it up
and i've never seen anyone else do this
and i'm like who taught you this
like someone had to teach you this
because no one else would ever do this
and i'm like
i bet his [ __ ] parents are freaks
what else do they do
do they like [ __ ] eat their toenails
like what else is going on in this
household like you can't trust them when
they do that [ __ ]
it's like it's like the family was like
let's make let's make some tea and it's
cold and then and then one day they
discovered
people drink tea and then and then i
really then i realized
i'm like [ __ ] this is the most british
thing ever because he got [ __ ] for it
for like a year and a half i think i'm
like
i think you'd be able to be in america
he literally got bullied for a year and
a half for making tea wrong
isn't that the most british thing you've
ever heard well-deserved
honestly like you you know like you know
like that [ __ ] meme where you know if
aliens ever
invaded like humanity and they had to
blend in with the crowd
that's the kind of [ __ ] we were looking
forward to be like oh you're you're on
[ __ ] impossible
honestly there's nothing more british
than being like being like
very possessive over our team being very
protective
did i tell you about the shittiest cup
of tea my brother ever made me okay
you made two of them you made two of
them you know and this is the this is
the problem
uh when you kind of do it half right and
then [ __ ] up one step is that it looks
good
it smells good it looks as it should so
the first time he did it for me i asked
him to make me a cup of tea and he
reluctantly said yes i can't remember
how i convinced him because he would
never do anything right he was
you should brother he never does
anything nice for me that's been in a
good mood
yeah i know i'm just doing something
right so he makes me a cup of tea and
i'm drinking it
and i'm like i get to the end like
he [ __ ] ripped the bag open
[Laughter]
because he never made a cup of tea
before so he assumed
the bag was like oh this is all this
[ __ ] in this bag
because i think i think what happened
was that he'd had instant coffee before
right and he thought he thought it
looked like instant coffee
so he thought that you ripped the bag
open pour in the perfectly portioned
instant tea and then he stirred it and
then i get to the end of this
and i [ __ ] choke him on these [ __ ]
his shitty tea leaves
and then i scolded him i never let him
forget it and then again
you know like a year or two later he
makes me another cup of tea right
and i can't [ __ ] up a cup of tea more
than once yeah right this is this is it
so this was actually at the paintballing
place i remember this because i was like
literally [ __ ] freezing right we're
covered in mud i'm like oh she want a
good cup of tea i was like oh when
you're on the cuz it was it was uh my
little brother
some of his friends some of my friends
and i was like oh you you're on the
tee duty so he goes for me he used to
make a cup of tea for like me
and like six of the people yeah i swear
it must have been like
you know like it was like some kind of
cult poisoning-esque thing
because we all drink our tea and when we
get to the bottom he [ __ ] left the
bag in
he put the milk in rice you can't right
you can't see them
and then when you get to it and a
[ __ ] teeth [ __ ] bag hit me in the
face
you literally got tea bags
the t-bag hit me in the goddamn face and
i'm like what the [ __ ]
i'm like you're british you're 15 years
of age you have no excuse this should
never have happened
this literally there should have been
things to stop this isn't this what
school is for of all the different ways
he could have [ __ ] up tea
he did all of them pretty sure he could
be exiled from england
right i'm pretty sure a lot of british
people would like kick you out of their
house
like that probably breaks it happened
right they're like
they're like [ __ ] europeans can't
make a call make a good cup of tea
this episode is sponsored by harry's
boys you look like you need a shave
thank god harry's just sponsoring us
right with harry's you don't need to
choose between having a great shave and
a fair price
neither should any guy in their life
especially connor and with father's day
right around the corner there's never
been a better time to try
or share the harry's experience thank
you dad let me tell you about the time
when i used harry's race
it's okay son i know we're no strangers
to meaning here but this is legitimately
a good razer and i use it and i keep
asking them to send me more
personally because it's actually that
good i highly recommend it
and it lasts a while it's really [ __ ]
good just no no no [ __ ] no cat
thank you very much son other son tell
me about this you can redeem a trial set
for just three dollars or get five
dollars off any shave set when you go to
harrys.com
trash taste you know what gentlemen
harry's delivers a close
comfortable shave at a fair price still
as low as
two dollars per refill harry's bought a
factory in germany that's been making
precision engineered blades for over 100
years
that's a long time and did you know they
have a 100 satisfaction guarantee harry
stands behind
the quality of their blades so much
they're offering a 100 money back
guarantee on harry's dot com new harry's
customers can get a starter set for just
three dollars
plus harry's is doing a limited time
offer for all customers starting now
through father's day
you can take five dollars off any shave
set at harry's dot com slash trash taste
what damn but but wait there's more
there's never truly been a better time
to try harry's go to harris.com
to start your own harry's journey or to
save a few bucks on a special gift for a
special dad in your life
sons i'd say that's a pretty special
offer thank you father back to the
episode i am curious though joey
like so what's the one sign you look for
to know that you're
talking like to a true aussie because
for us brits it all revolves around tea
what's australia patriotic about um
it's good question because i've only
cockroaches how many
do you do you spray not a true aussie
i don't know um i'm not very patriotic
excited
no no no because i was like england's
not very patriotic but when it comes to
tea
yeah we're [ __ ] patriotic as [ __ ]
overall are we not patriotic i feel like
i met a lot i mean not to say patriotic
people
i mean not to say you know like i don't
love my country or whatever but like
yeah i don't know
i just i guess maybe
god it's hard with australia because i
feel it's such a melting pot of
different cultures yeah that like
all of my friends in high school had
like something specific about their
family that made it like
very distinctively aussie right i'd say
like
i don't know maybe the type of bee you
drink
the type of water i drink really
straightforward
yeah if you say fosters then you are
getting exiled from australia
um i don't know and then i guess like
what you order at a pub
i don't know yeah basically we don't
really have a 40 year old virgin
scene where he's describing how it feels
to feel a boob
right it's just like not even remotely
real it's like joey be like
it's the type of beer they want yeah it
feels like a
bag of sand that's right yeah
if you get that reference that'll make a
lot of sense if you don't that'll make
you know
go watch the four-year-old version yeah
if you haven't watch that film
i don't know like with it like i feel
like you're with aussies
it's just you start talking to them and
then you kind of get a sense of it right
like you just know
you know how much of an aussie an aussie
is yeah
with like just the way that they
interact in conversation and the way you
get
very like immediately close to them oh
yeah i feel that as well for me like
whenever i meet an aussie um
i have this i have this thing where it's
like it's the cpm
like you know how music has beats per
minute yeah so when you talk to an
aussie they have [ __ ] per minute
right we're so confused
it was like cost per million
like the amount of times they use the c
word in a single sentence yeah you can
[ __ ] count that [ __ ]
and like put it put it as a cpm i swear
to god
that is true that is true i don't know
what you're typing words per minute
i want to know your
[Laughter]
that is true we call we call our mates c
word and we call c
words mates that's how it works in
australia that's exactly how it works
like
if you if you see a friend from you know
across the street and you want to call
out to them you'll be like i
can't but if you bump into someone at a
pub right yeah you'd be like oh mate
that's i feel like if if you hear an
aussie doing that
that's a true aussie all right if
they're not afraid to say the c word
going back to like the [ __ ] bugs and
spiders as someone who did grow up in
australia
some of the [ __ ] you've seen yeah right
do they scare you at all or are you just
like unfazed by them now
i'm only scared if i know it's poisonous
okay yeah so like there was this uh
there was this insect so on journey
across japan
i talked about a couple of episodes ago
but like we went into this like area
where there was
a lot of creepy crawlies right and chris
was not okay with any of the creepy
crawls
as the true bridge he is he's not okay
with the creepy crawlies and there was
this one particular insect that i saw
which
i mean you'll see it hopefully in the
episode when it comes out but it the
only way i can describe it is
it looks like a centipede and a
cockroach had a baby
that's what it looks like it's like it
moves around like a cockroach but it's
kind of got like the body of a centipede
it is like true nightmare fuel what the
[ __ ] i didn't even know i didn't even
know if you want to like put the image
on the screen or whatever
like yeah it's horrible so like i saw
that
in this like little area chris obviously
freaked the [ __ ] out
yeah and i was freaking out because i
didn't know because there's
this i think there's like a breed of
centipede in japan that's poisonous
so all centipedes poisonous oh okay
some of them taste good
that's what my dad said i'm pretty sure
they're editable
are they yeah of course i mean i'm sure
that i'm sure they are i'm sure
source of protein i'm sure cockroaches
are edible too i don't
want to eat them yeah yeah i'll give it
to my dad that's why i love the food on
kitchen nutmeg because it always comes
free exactly but like
i didn't know if that was the breed of
like poisonous centipede right so
that's what was freaking me out i was
like if this thing is poisonous
then i'm scared joe's like get out the
[ __ ] pokedex it's not like
a poisonous literally on the spot i
looked it up i was like
i was like poisonous centipede japan and
i looked it up
and i like referenced it i was like okay
it's not it
yeah it's like the filtered version with
the like the the nice one you're looking
at irl like [ __ ]
expectations like a mad
yeah i don't know it's like because you
know obviously there's lots of like
creepy crawls and [ __ ] in australia but
like
the reason why i'm scared of a lot of
them is because a lot of them
can kill me yeah i mean i i'm not okay
with that
listen i don't like bugs at all i i'm
frankly quite terrified of them but
i'll deal with them still i think that's
you know that's that's you know
that's admirable that's manly that's
admirable admitting that you're a little
[ __ ] and then dealing with it anyway
that's
that's real men like if i know it's not
poisonous i'll [ __ ] touch it but like
what at what point do you see like an
insect or creepy cause
i don't get scared by any singular
insect it's like
the thing that terrifies me most
actually it's like swarms
well yeah like of course but like no
one's gonna be like okay
but okay okay like swamps if anything
terrifies the [ __ ] out of it like there
was a video and it was like
uh south australian farm gets over over
wrote like run by
mice all the mice and there i [ __ ] you
not dude it looked like the floor was
moving
there was so many mice running it was
terrifying
and if i'm sitting there that's my farm
i'm like well i'm out of a job
i have it it's yours yes i'll die
what the [ __ ] am i gonna do i feel like
there are so many
like stories i'm here from just talking
to australians that i'm just like man
did god how much should god just hate
australia and yet people still
have found a way to live there okay to
be fair my place my parents place is
like
right our backyard is right next to a
national park right so our house was
basically just
a house for creepy crawlies it was like
it was like the first destination like
we got snakes and spiders
all the [ __ ] time but after a while
we're just like
i mean we do live right in the [ __ ]
bush is there like a
is it like was there an old medieval
method of determining what's poisonous
or not or was it just give it to some
poor
trial by fire in it was it was it really
yeah i've always i've always thought
about this like i must have just had one
rich guy who was like well
random a bunch of the people who can't
afford much i mean how do you think they
how do you think people discovered like
what mushrooms were poisonous
there's no tragic though you're just
like oh hi what's your job well i'm a
poison tester i'm through for three at
the moment
tomorrow will go well like you know what
blows my mind how the [ __ ]
did like people in japan figure out
which part of the puffer fish wasn't
poisonous
like how many people had to die to know
the exact methods but why also
did someone die they were like they're
gonna try
we're 100 to zero on the puffer fish
right now but maybe yeah maybe there's
one time
there has to be somewhere on this thing
that's edible right like after you find
out
something is poisonous i think it's okay
to give up and not eat it you know
that's what i thought like it's is it
like like
we've got to make sure the last guy
might have like you know side effects
yeah yeah yeah
beforehand have you had the puffer fish
yeah a couple of times
i've heard it's not great listen if i'm
gonna die
i want it to be not worthy right like i
want the wrist to be worth the reward
yeah of course and it just looks like
really shitty like um
like sushi what's up what does it even
what does it even taste like
nothing that's what i've actually tasted
that's what i've heard like it's just
grown men wanting to die
yeah it's lit no it's literally just a
status symbol
it's to just say that you've had a
pufferfish because i've seen the videos
and i'm just like this just looks like
you're eating
like [ __ ] cardboard you know it it
tastes like it doesn't it doesn't look
like you're
like actually you do know what it tastes
like the soy sauce that you dip it in
that's what it tastes like i i love
unagi
is one of my favorite japanese dishes
yep and i found out
if you cook it incorrectly it's [ __ ]
poisonous yeah no one told me that
that's
it that's why it's so expensive it's
it's poisonous as [ __ ] it can kill you
you know i'll [ __ ] risk it
that's one thing i will risk yeah yeah
cause it [ __ ] slaps and then i was
like you know what this ad the element
of danger adds to the taste now
frankly but if it's if it's not very
good tasting i feel that's why a lot of
people eat puffer fish as well it's like
the element of danger adds to the taste
whatever
they're tasting i don't know
do you reckon there's a guy god kill me
if it's this time around like i'm pretty
sure that's like whoever like you know
it's i i get it right because you know
when you see like poisonous berries
yeah i still really want to try them
like because they look so delicious
when you're a kid yeah and the you cakes
there's so many poisonous berries is
that
that's how nature [ __ ] with you dude
yeah the ones that look the most
delicious
yeah yeah yeah cause i like those bright
little red things you know you see them
yeah oh okay that looks so [ __ ]
delicious right
they look like like mini tomatoes right
i just want to have a
get a bunch of those and just see what
happens you know just
see what happens that's probably how
that's probably how people found out
they were poisonous
right well i get it i mean okay okay
let's say you know you haven't got much
food you know you struggling all right
you go to the
you have to wander through the forest
whatever you see a bunch of you see a
bush
enough food for the family what do you
do enough food to kill the family nobody
told you they're
poisonous you know yeah like also who
who got poisoned by a mushroom was like
no no
it was supposed to be this type of
mushroom and goes out and tries another
one
that's like a very bold thing like who's
doing this well someone had to right so
someone did it back in the day it must
have been people with too much money
being like
i will literally pay you a thousand
dollars to like literally like i missed
it
like when's the mr beast video coming
out where he's like i pay people one
hundred thousand dollars to try
mushrooms to find out which one's
poisonous
how much shitake mushroom will kill you
eat mushrooms last one to survive wins a
million dollars
everyone gets those i don't know if you
want people to do it just make it a
[ __ ] tick tock challenge yeah yes
so i found this mushroom in my cupboard
tik tok mushroom challenge let's get the
death cap challenge
[Laughter]
today i'm eating a death cap hope if i
survive oh my god
you know i think i would rather try my
luck eating a poisonous mushroom
and just try my chance of surviving as
opposed to putting my hand on my iphone
for four days
you know for that keep your hand on the
iphone oh yeah oh
that way i think i would actually rather
poison myself than do that for four days
that sounds [ __ ] horrible yeah i know
i'm sure the pain would be over within
two days if you just get to go to the
hospital get it all sorted
just be fine get slight arthritis you'll
be all right i mean
it's not a bad one you know i'm sure
there's i'm sure there's mushrooms out
there just make you like
very much vomit i'm yeah
yeah probably sure
would you rather vomit profusely for
like four hours or would you rather put
your hand on an iphone
for four hours and you can't sleep i
mean i probably you mean four days it's
like four days four days yeah four hours
that's very easy
have you ever tried to stay up past like
one day dude like it
how long's how how long is the longest
you've stayed up like a day and a half
for me for me it's like 36 hours yeah
yeah yeah 36 hours
and that's where it starts to get like
[ __ ] weird yeah like your brain
starts to like want to [ __ ] like turn
off
yeah definitely so like and i feel like
by the third day
what on earth is going through your head
like i couldn't do that and
that's why i would rather eat the
[ __ ] mushrooms that might poison me
maybelline can you google it is there
any mushrooms that'll just make me throw
up a little bit
like a little like not kill me but like
is this like is this an option i just
want to make sure
i mean i wouldn't want to do either
personally but personally both
sounds like hell but uh someone's gonna
come up with they'll be like now it's
the mushroom cleanse
you know this mushroom this mushroom
will detox your body yeah cause it's
making you [ __ ] lose it all
that's what they're doing man oh my god
mascarine muscular muscular what does it
make you do
for i guess 15 after 15 30 minutes
you'll start getting like
diarrhea and decreased blood pressure oh
wow
that sounds pretty bad oh that sounds
yeah that sounds pretty bad if you're
vomiting but you recover within 24 hours
that's good then brilliant what was it
called again uh mascara
mascara mascara muscari challenge
i'm kidding safety reasons please you're
joking this is a joke this is not a joke
we are just joking around please don't
do that um it's only ten percent less
deadly than the cinnamon challenge so
it's pretty it's okay
it makes you wonder how that was ever
allowed god remember the [ __ ]
cinnamon challenge
did you guys ever do that no i've never
done any
the only challenge i've done is like the
ice bucket challenge yeah i did the ice
bucket yeah because that's like
it's like that's for a good cause for a
good cause also you know it's pretty
it's pretty pretty easy yeah it's like
breathe oxygen for 20 minute challenge
it's like
i guess yeah you get mild discomfort for
like a second
that's that's that was the ice bucket
challenge right
i got tanked though i never did it
though because i was feeling quite lazy
i i i didn't want to get a bucket
i like what i didn't want to get when
you get a bucket big enough when you're
like 15.
i don't know did you do from your dad
from do you does your house not have one
like other probably somewhere i just
don't want to find it just like admire
like a mop and bucket right everyone
every house has a moment just get like
a [ __ ] mop bucket over my just get
like a big like uh
like pot yeah that's what some of my
friends well i mean perhaps when i was
15 maybe i should have been
you know i wasn't too fond of doing it
anyway i was like oh i don't have a
bucket oh [ __ ]
hey jerry obviously well there's a thing
though
[ __ ] like this it's always like when you
like what is me a 15 year old kid on my
facebook with 200 friends what is this
going to what is this going to help
that's what i thought oh yeah this was
like pretty youtube wasn't there this
was pretty youtube no no
no wasn't it no no no no no no no no
yeah oh for you yeah just like when i
was in high school yeah this is coming
out and i just thought what am i
really sickly connor what are you going
to contribute here huh a little a little
bit of an ego boost
taking part in something huh yeah just
do it with your mates what is it
come on you already [ __ ] help me
you're not doing this for charity
because your friend tagged you yeah
exactly can't even get the clout from it
what's the point what's the point
why do i need to charity when you can't
get cloud for what no i was 15.
50 15 years a day the charity are like
the biggest dick 15 year old so like
i've got like 10 bucks
have it have it i don't even i could i
could have bought something good for
[Music]
this
like i feel like i'm not gonna lie when
i was 15
i probably didn't give any money to
charity because i didn't have any yeah
obviously
most most of us didn't have any money it
was like when my mum gave me a pound and
she was like you know when it was like
wait your own uh
school yeah yeah oh the own clothes day
i don't close that yeah yeah
i'd give a pound i'd be like it's on me
it's on me
oh my god this is not from my mom i
swear
guys guys don't worry i'm i'm i'll i'll
break out the bears
we all got this from our parents yeah
yeah i got changed guys this is what i
hated
like i wish there was like some kind of
like system where why do i got to be the
messenger for my mom's money like what
what am i gonna bring the [ __ ] in
what do you mean the messenger like i go
surely can you like collect the [ __ ]
from my parents why do i have to bring
in money from for my parents you know
it's a pound it's scary you know i carry
a [ __ ] briefcase of cash i just spend
it you know i just
i never did actually i knew i knew
people in my school who just [ __ ]
spend it
i would i mean there was there was
plenty of good places in my town there's
a thing called uh
a pound bakery mm-hmm do you ever have
one of these no it's like i think it's a
normal
uk no no it's it's even cheaper than
greg's oh
[ __ ] you could get two pasties for a
pound the [ __ ] the capacity
oh yeah pasty is a very british thing as
well i've realized this after moving
like a pastry yeah well yeah but it's
kind of like it's like a
lot of meat inside of it and then yeah
yeah it's got some meat potatoes
so let me tell you let me tell you the
most popular fillings for pasties okay
it's cheesed onion just a bunch of
cheese and onion
okay thank you like a beef pasty as well
right there's a kitten yeah
kidney kidney kidney and steak yeah yeah
that's like
like a pie kind of kind of
street but more pastry pies are a little
too thick the crust uh they're really
popular uh there's a sausage roll
that that's always there that's one of
them that's not really a that's a
sausage roll
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah right and
that'd be like uh my one my personal
favorite was the sausage bean and cheese
melt
pasta which is just sausage beans and
cheese shoved into like a pastry
melted ice cream it's like now that i
think about it it's probably
like the closest thing you'd get not
like in terms of like
cultural importance as like an onigiri
like
i just like realized that as we were
talking the reason why it became popular
is because in when they like because
obviously
coal mining was a massive thing in the
uk is that they needed food that
wouldn't go bad and they would literally
put these things in their pockets
yeah in the vines right right right
and for some reason we decided that that
was just great so now it's your only
year
now yeah yeah that's british but you
could get jelly doughnuts yeah
two pastries which is pretty [ __ ]
filling things for one pound and i was
like holy [ __ ] this is insane that's
pretty good yeah too pretty and they
taste good
yeah they're really good [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i
like your school dinners back in the day
[ __ ] dreadful i'd rather eat the
mushroom than maybe
it was absolutely terrible the only
thing that was good was like toast for
some reason tastes really good at school
and it always toasts you behind this the
toast tastes different
like wildly different wherever you go i
mean like this type of bread
it's like it's like it's not even like i
feel like toast doesn't even taste
remotely the same because toast here
tastes completely different to anywhere
else
yeah but as well like when you make
toast at home it has a completely
different taste
to where you get toast at a restaurant
like it's it's wildly different i think
it doesn't even taste like i don't know
like back in the day i i think
like [ __ ] school dinners were kind of
like prison food
almost right you'd go in the [ __ ]
cafeteria there was always these like
you know the lunch ladies
they'd always look depressed as [ __ ] and
you'd come in with like your tray
and now that i think about you kind of
just felt like you're in prison we
didn't even have that
we just had like a cafeteria like like a
like a we called it a tuck shop
yeah a talk shop right yeah like you
guys have talk shops right no
that's a very australian thing i just
realized so it's like a tuck shop in
australian schools is basically this
like
booth that you can just go and just buy
like food items
like right just it's not even a cafe
it's not even a room
it's stall it's like a stall basically
because like our schools
didn't really a lot of schools in
australia i think don't really have like
full-on cafeterias because none of them
are like big enough to have
full-on cafeteria so like like the only
like experience of like cafeterias i
ever had as a kid was like
watching the simpsons okay like that was
the closest i ever got to like a school
cafeteria because like australian
schools like there are no schools
i didn't know a single school in my area
or in australia at all that had
that like school lunches it's like some
guy just [ __ ] drops off some [ __ ] in
his truck
are you [ __ ] good for her kids you've
got some [ __ ] sausages here
yeah you literally just go to like a
stall kind of thing and there'd be like
a a canteen lady there or
a cafeteria lady you just buy stuff i
just like smooth talk them or i should
always be really really [ __ ] nice to
the cafeteria ladies
and gentlemen extra food yeah oh yeah
whenever whenever like my friend's mom
was like the cafeteria lady they're like
hey come on come on let me in let me
just give you some of the
[Music]
like go back thank you so much that was
great that was fantastic
because right no did they give you
anything for them oh yeah yeah so
okay after a while of doing this they
would like they would like
make specialized things for me wow
because i i would always my mates gave
me some [ __ ] for it because they're like
why are you [ __ ] sucking up to them
i'm like well look at my [ __ ] meal
i'm eating like a king today
they custom make the [ __ ] it's not just
do you know who this man is he says
thank you
so they used to make like so this is
again like another [ __ ] really
british thing jacket potatoes
jacket potatoes yeah i know jack of
potatoes literally just like
it's it's a potato it's a potato pot you
stab it a bunch
uh maybe you cut it open a little bit
you put butter in it you
baked potato oh baked potato you wrap it
up it's called jack potato yeah
it's just potato with butter and they
would just give it to you like just that
and i was like
come on i'm better than this and i was
like i know you got some chewer in the
back there and you got some beans and
cheese can you put that [ __ ] all over it
so they would make like normally it was
just you get a jack potato but
because i was really nice to them they
would they would put like tuna in there
which i [ __ ] love
beans and cheese as well and i would
rock up like yeah boys
i mean like a king today that's very
good
you're literally like james bond that
[ __ ] you can't be like close
the reason why i did it is because i
realized that like one of the other kids
who was like way older than me got like
a bunch of
uh like really it looked like he always
had like everyone else's tray was like
peasant tray and this guy always had
like a stacked [ __ ] tray and i was
like what does this guy do
because like they don't give you extra
if you ask they just laugh at you right
so i was like oh [ __ ] what's he doing
and i watched him and he was just like
smooth talking
i'm just saying like thank you a bunch i
was like who knows all you do is just
say thank you and be
nice and say the phone is good and they
give you more what's the best part of
the school dinner you remember
i feel like i know what you're going to
say because i i feel like what reminds
me of you
they say like turkey twizzlers or
something no no no no what reminded me
of this was because we went uh
there's like a local bar near us and
it's like i don't even know how to
describe
what this like what the theme of this
bar is right
um this this bar that we go to that has
just like the most
random assortment of foods you could
think it's all good it's all great
uh and so we ordered this like i can't
remember what we ordered but we ordered
like
some dish and what comes out is the
[ __ ] smiley potato chips
and i can't remember what dish we
ordered but i remember we came we
came out and like the three of us just
reverted back to being like
seven years old being like potato chips
you know this is what it looks like if
you didn't have it wherever you grew up
it's basically just the funimation logo
it's the fundamental logo with eyes it's
weird because it has like a taste that
is so unique yeah
because it's not it's not just it's not
fried it's it's it's not fries it's not
like potatoes it's just got such a
unique taste
and i'm sure anyone who didn't grow up
with it would think it tastes like [ __ ]
or i could be a billionaire and i'll be
like charles
heat up the smiley faces won't you bring
in the smiley face ever since i saw
those
at bad restaurant i've been trying to
find them they're so good
like i can't find them anywhere because
they don't sell them in like
supermarkets
because i like because because it's it's
like it's so bizarre because like the
restaurant i wouldn't call it posh but
it's like
it's like uh the decor is extremely nice
very i'd say very almost very it's very
yeah it's it's
it's very nice it's it's not it's okay
is everywhere yeah
so i'm just i'm just i would just i just
laughed right because they bring out
this dish and they were just probably
like
this is imported potato from britain
enjoy lads and i'm just thinking here
this is just school dinner chips right
here man
this is 10 cents a piece already
this is like currency in light
elementary school
but yeah those were the one things i
remember like that was universal when
every school dinner we had in the uk
every
every kid remembers they're like dead
ass in primary school it was like
currency like you would like trade other
food items with people i think for
smiling
i don't i think it's phased out now
because school dinners from what i've
heard in the uk
are a lot more healthy than they used to
be and that's because uh do you know
jamie oliver
yeah yeah so i think like back when i
was on a crusade
yeah oh really for like healthy school
dinners and apparently it worked
i'm jealous because i've seen some of
the school dinners that they get to get
nowadays
and man they be eating good they be
they're getting like a [ __ ]
three-course meal with like roast
chicken and all that [ __ ]
i'm just like the fanciest thing i had
in my cafeteria was uh
it was a chicken tender roll yeah
literally which is literally
a bun with two chicken tenders in it
four dollars you feel like bring in your
own
uh like lunch like yeah i always do
packed lunch yes i used to for a while i
can't remember why
i had cause i had school lunch and i had
packages for some time i don't know why
i didn't didn't
but i remember i used to like trade do
you ever trade stuff with the other kids
yeah because your mom would put stuff in
your box and you're like well i'm not
like don't like this but
that guy likes this thing yeah i want to
try i always
used to trade uh like kit kat for cheese
strings i like cheese string but they
oh cheese string i remember cheese
strawberries yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah because i'm not
being funny obviously i love kitkat
but frankly eating a cheese string as a
kid is probably one of the most
enjoyable things oh yeah of course you
know still to this day
i still really enjoy the process if you
think she's i think it's very satisfying
um and i i traded always always i traded
my my like kit kat for this
this kid's cheese straight and then when
my mom just asked your mom to get cheap
i think actually the cheese string is
actually more expensive oh really
and the kit kats in the packs the kits
are pretty cheap that makes sense yeah
yeah there was like these like the
branded cheese strings as well yeah
like the cheese strips when i told my
mom i felt like
i like never saw her like weirdly upset
about something where
she i was like man why are you upset
about me trading cheese string so you
could have told me
what did you tell me and i'm like i
don't think it's a big deal i'm i'm i'm
out here hustling mom it's fine
i got it
let me be i liked it it was fun it was
fun scouting out what everyone else had
he'd be like
tray trade off
literally i would go up to the kids be
like i received cheese strips i don't
know it was a kid for some reason i
didn't have any like qualms about going
up to a kid i'd be like i like that we
should trade what do you think
oh yeah of course i feel like i feel
like the only time you can do that and
it's not weird
and then sometimes kids will be like i
feel like they didn't they wanted the
trade but they were skeptical as to why
i wanted the trade don't know what's
wrong with it what did you do to the
kitkat
i just want i just want it like yeah i
don't know con you got a reputation for
hustling i don't know
the kids i was always jealous of were
the kids that had the daily lunchables
because that looks so
fun because dirty lunchables it's
basically like build-a-bear
but for lunch you've had a lunch i've
had a lunchable but
it's it's it's the pack that comes with
like the biscuits the cheese and the ham
oh yeah like little sandwich yeah i
don't know why as a kid that just seemed
so fun
but it was like expensive as [ __ ] for
like a kid like they thought
those kids were eating everything had
like negative nutrition
actively took it out of your body also
you know lunchables they i think i
don't have the same brand it's dairy lee
like the dairy dunkers did you like
those
oh what were they against i like the
chocolate sauce ones
they didn't have chocolate sauce right
right uh oh the cheese sauce ones those
cheese sauce ones which i
really [ __ ] love i think originally
they were chocolate where it was like uh
like a biscuit bread kind of it's like a
biscuit like
breadsticks and then the other half like
chocolate right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then they had like a cheese
version and then they had this one
that i've never heard of the
cheeseburger yeah it was really popular
in the uk yeah yeah i love [ __ ]
love those things like i [ __ ] i
[ __ ] put those away
um and then i i was eating them up until
like age like 21
yeah because they had like they had like
a version where like
it was like some herb stick or something
and i really [ __ ] loved it
and i was legit eating it in 2021 and
they changed the recipe and i was like
you've lost a long time
it actually tasted like [ __ ] am i i
don't know what happened wow i wanted
the email hq
being like how [ __ ] dead did you
change the flavor did you change the
rest tell me you changed the flavor tell
me my taste buds haven't changed this
tastes like [ __ ]
i'm not crazy have you guys ever had
like a food product
like later in life that you just like
couldn't believe that you
waited this long in life before you had
this one food product
because i'll tell you what i was gonna
say you must have a very yeah
i mean because thinking about it you
have this super specific situation
did you have this super specific
situation
because i'll tell you mine actually um
because i didn't try nutella for the
first time
until i was 25
how did you avoid nutella okay because i
was like everywhere yeah because i was a
kid i wasn't allowed nutella right
because my parents wouldn't let it in
there yeah yeah yeah
cause because it's basically just
[ __ ] chocolate right it's just
basically chocolate it's actually worse
[Music]
so i just went my entire life without
trying without trying nutella i don't
know how
but like how how has nutella been
branded as just like this thing you can
spread on toast and people eat for
breakfast
right and that feels like a cheat code
to me you know because i remember trying
it for the first time and i'm just like
this is the most amazing snack i've i've
ever tried in my life it's just like
the [ __ ] gates of babylon opened i'm
just like oh my god
i have discovered gods
it literally goes on like everything
yeah i know i can open the jar and just
start to glow
like my favorite thing is like this like
oh god i cover which one youtube video
is called again i forget this one
but there's literally a video where uh
they were like
uh it was about this whole the deception
of nutella being a breakfast product
yeah and there was this part in it where
they go around to parents who are
feeding their kids in nutella and
they're like do you know how much sugar
is in nutella
they're like no and they tell them
they're like there's a lot of sugar
like a lot yeah like oh my god i had no
idea
and they're like they look like so
dumbfounded like what are you
serious the chocolate spread the pure
100
chocolate flavor that i'm spreading on a
piece of bread twice
is bad for myself you're kidding me it's
just i'm surprised surprise pikachu face
oh my god i've been feeding my kid
chocolate this whole time it's like
what did you think it was no one thought
it wasn't chocolate
we all know that nutella is chocolate
just because it's like kind of liquidy
like very viscous
you think it just gets a pass yeah why
yeah why isn't that nutella as a person
yeah coco puffs is like no no no no no
quickest branding joey branding is
powerful
it's like like how did how did we how
did they get away with this for so long
i don't know
nutella [ __ ] slaps but i i knew as
soon as i tasted it it's [ __ ]
unhealthy as [ __ ] oh yeah um but it
tastes amazing literally anyone who
knows what sugar tastes like can be like
i think this is this is pretty bad it's
pretty bad yeah pretty bad for years i
think actually you know
because my parents would only let me
have it on uh holidays oh really that's
how like taboo it was it was like this
is
special occasions no i think my parents
let me have nutella like
pretty much every morning if i wanted it
but then i very quickly was like
this is too much like this is too much
sugar even for like my eight-year-old
body i know this is too much sugar
like i'm just like i like i'm just like
as a now i just think
kids you're not allowed to have ice
cream for breakfast but nutella that's
okay yeah i'm just like to me they're
they're on the same [ __ ] level you
should put nutella on ice cream
that sounds amazing nutella flavored
nutella on some like [ __ ] vanilla ice
cream i should slap
i mean that's it's just a dessert right
i mean it is yes
it's just chocolate it's literally just
chocolate
just a bit it's just a bit of a nutty
chocolate right it's ridiculous
you know what's another thing i [ __ ]
grab i think i just like grew out of
like all
like viscous breakfast spreads biscuits
breakfast
oh yes what's your favorite what's your
favorite viscous breakfast this
breakfast no one has ever described it
like that
you could have said breakfast spread i
have to put the word
i'm pretty sure that's the first time in
the history of man that those three
words have been put in the same sentence
together
this is like alien alien alien to the
best of your knowledge describe what
this spread is
i do love this viscous breakfast spread
cumin
no no no okay okay i i use i
specifically use the word viscous
because like
i could change i could feel someone
doing the [ __ ] lawnmower
in his [ __ ] head trying to form that
sentence because okay i
i use the word viscous because like jam
for instance
i know you can talk about peanut butter
and jelly no no no that's her
but like jam for instance right that's
not viscous
you know what i mean depends you can
make it it doesn't it doesn't stick to
the roof of your mouth
like nutella does all right i love a
good [ __ ] jam but the thing is it's
like
not only did i like grow out of nutella
but also like peanut butter i used to
[ __ ]
love peanuts i don't know a single
person in the uk who ate peanut butter
as a child
right but like no no i didn't eat peanut
butter really
yeah because i ate it as a child but
then after a while i was like i
i don't know i don't think i like this
just the fact that every time i take a
bite and
it just feels like i just swallowed a
mouthful of glue it's just like
honestly it's viscous the viscous it's
the viscosity
of peanut butter that i don't like nine
out of ten people i know who have
peanut butter is just for catching mice
that's why i had it really yeah i i only
bought it because apparently mice
[ __ ] love it i don't well yeah i
don't blame them i mean
i'm i'm licking the floor so i mean it
caught me
god damn i got my tongue i'm just ready
for the drake meme like peanut butter
and jelly sandwich
i sleep like biscuits breakfast spread
real [ __ ] no yeah i
i remember like because i hadn't tried
peanut but that was another
food item that i didn't try until later
in life was peanut butter i've never had
just peanut butter on like a sandwich or
something yeah and i remember trying it
for the first time and i was very
underwhelmed by it it was like the most
five out of ten food item i've ever like
tasted in my life
like what about its viscosity doesn't
that [ __ ] just like stick to your mouth
okay do you do you okay which which kind
of spreads did you have did you have
like the chunky spread or did you have
like the smooth spread
uh i mean i went either all right i've
never had a spread of peanut butter
you've never had a spread of peanut
butter never had reese's cupcakes which
i you know i wasn't i also hate the
viscosity of those well i remember the
first time
we just want to say wisconsin i very
much had
like the kombucha team moment when i
first tried the reese's cupcakes
right and i was like i had it and i was
like oh oh
i think the one thing i don't like about
reese's cups is that again it's the
peanut butter it just
overpowers everything and it's like a
certain this
is the point i don't know if that's the
point i don't know if that's there's
like something about the peanut butter
that i just
i think i just don't like peanut butter
foreigners try and figure out american
food yeah like what is going on here
i think i think i just i just realized
like right now i just think i don't like
peanuts
okay americans is it normal to feel like
violently uncomfortable after eating
more than two of those cups is that
normal
melina is that normal do you feel does
your stomach feel really how many how
many rhesus cups can you eat you can eat
like a bunch
too yeah yeah you start to feel like
real uncomfortable right
why i mean there was no pat there was
they came in a nice pack of three
so i assumed i eat all three oh you
don't [ __ ]
that is that it's that is the biggest
lie about everything i've ever told
you you share share bags my ass why
would they why are those i mean my hand
fits so perfectly
that's like saying oh you can break off
a kick cat and share it with another
person no one [ __ ] does that [ __ ]
just open it's eating especially now i
don't want i don't want someone with
their [ __ ]
sweaty hands snapping a kit kat that
whole palm reaching over the whole
kitkat to snap it
that's what you have to do i don't trust
the person who tries to do it like that
that's weird you want to clean
yeah you want that but i also don't want
your whole palm touching there that's a
lot a little too much palm
so i don't i i frankly we'll just buy
our own kitkats you know
just just eat the [ __ ] or honestly in
the packet rip it in the packet because
you can do that if you oh yeah you can
if you have
big brains that's two big brains but
sometimes you forget you've opened it up
and you're like [ __ ]
i can't i can't wrap it back up grab the
packaging just
you gotta do like have you ever seen the
kitkat adverts where you got like the
foil wrapping and then you just like
split it in the middle
with like a knife no no with your finger
you like it it's just splits perfectly
what was it is does this is your
fingernail long enough no it
it is have you liked it
did that advert stop getting played or
something i've never seen
that oh my god i gotta [ __ ] show you
after after the young i've never split a
kitkat
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait i have not
how do you eat kitkats just [ __ ] take
it out of the package to eat it
okay i haven't done that but i don't
believe you that you've never split no
because like because the kitkats i
always used to get were like the
kind of mini packets of kitkats so it's
like it would be in a bag
you've never had a single kitkat you've
not had
do you just [ __ ] bite that [ __ ]
without splitting it yeah no
no no
i don't believe that you've never
cracked the kitkat i don't i don't do it
on a
on the [ __ ] wrecks though if i need a
kitkat who the [ __ ] even kick cat
often no but like every time i have
and [ __ ] no it's the hidden one guys
like it's such a mess like crumbs go
everywhere the wafer falls
the structural integrity has been
compromised frankly it doesn't matter
because two seconds later it's all going
in your mouth
pretty sure like society would crumble
if everyone did that joey jesus christ
this is why we ran out of toilet paper
is this an australian thing that i just
don't know this is this i know this is
just a me
i know whatever shamed you about this in
your life there's no way you went
through school eating kitkats like that
no goldberg i never ate kitkats in
school
kitkats were me things in my room
does it say on the packaging must crack
one at a time in order to eat
successfully no it doesn't it's it's
like it's like
only drinking beer via like shot dying
yeah okay as a one-off i get it but like
that shouldn't be your primary go-to
method of drinking a beer again you know
like
like stabbing a hole in the bottom and
[ __ ] drinking that shouldn't be your
like go-to method
you know what i mean it's like that it's
like that's nothing like that
it's just like that it is like that
you're literally making it like
harder to eat i'm not i'm making it easy
because i'm saving the
my [ __ ] palms from getting all
chocolatey by doing this
i mean i just like open it up halfway
and then grab it by the packaging and
then just [ __ ] there's a reason there
are crevices in the kitkat joey
there are reasons for it it's it's it's
literally designed into the [ __ ] food
product
it's designed to be eaten a certain way
joey look sometimes
i want to break the rules all right [ __ ]
society do you ever just like wake up
and remember that like toblerone like
took out like 50 percent of the [ __ ]
chocolate
i just can't believe they did that still
i still get it you know you know
toblerone yeah
yeah have you seen the modern the modern
ones no you know how the gaps used to be
very i would argue perfect you know
where the one went
up the next yeah yeah yeah yeah you
could easily just do that right yeah
it's not like that yeah like like what's
kitkat shut up
[Applause]
i bought too many at the airport yeah i
had i had to start you know just getting
a little wild
it's just [ __ ] deep throats
have you not seen have you not seen what
they look like their own deep throat
challenge
mr beast you can deep throat the most
total around to ten thousand dollars
yeah so i think the uh because i was out
of the uk by this point right yeah
but uh so toblerone you know what the
toblerone looks like it looks like it
looks like this chat
not chat [ __ ] audience [ __ ] i've been
watching too much
twitch but so i think one year they just
decided
to make less toblerones or like
they made the gaps a little bigger so
this is the original turbo yeah yeah
that's right
yeah you're gonna [ __ ] cry yeah uh
this is it now
yeah so that can't be real that cannot
be
real that's real yeah that is real that
is real are you [ __ ] me
yeah why are the toblerone social
distances
i just i just give me some room
sometimes i just wake up at night and i
just remember they did that
i got away with it and they're still
like okay did they get away with it i
don't know i'm pretty sure like they
i haven't i haven't heard of recent
memory of people buying tower
i'd like to think that like even like
you know like this that this like
plummeted their stock but i don't think
it did i think sure people write it
because of this
that that's like the impression i got
even if i'd known about it back in the
day i would have rioted because i i
remember it was like
it was just when i moved out the uk
because i can't remember if i was living
when did they do this
was this when you were living in the uk
so i must have just moved to thailand or
something right i remember moving to
thailand and one day i wake up in my
time
my entire [ __ ] feed is just people
complaining about the toblerone
it's just it's like they didn't even try
and hide how much chocolate they were
taking away yeah
i just fill it with some [ __ ] make it
less tasty
like don't ruin the because one of the
best things about a toblerone
is that you get so god damn much sure
you get a [ __ ] ton
like arguably one piece of toe bone is
too much that [ __ ] lasts you
yeah i think actually like eating a
single piece of like
the triangle is actually uncomfortable
it's almost too much it is super
shockingly always the best part because
it's good
[ __ ] too it tastes great it's the
perfect amount where you're like
i i don't even want to go for another
one i'll save it for the next day yeah i
also learned as well because i used to
always snap it like away
yeah yeah did you do that as well yeah
yeah i did that yeah but then the way
that i actually do is to push it inward
and it snaps easy
oh like that yeah you snap it in it just
breaks off
but now you'll never get to experience
it the design is fundamentally changed
so
wait how are you supposed to snap the
new ones now i don't know [ __ ] it with a
[ __ ] knife smack it against the
concrete or something i don't know
with a knife i mean you don't need to
snap it it will probably just like
it's so it's so long that it'll probably
just break under this like straight
yeah yeah yeah oh my god why do they do
this why are they masking my boy like
that
i i couldn't believe they did it i'm
still like wait i wake up in a cold
sweat how have i only just found out
about this
i'll tell you what if it's the uk only
or not i'll tell you what i'll tell you
what i think is an
underrated snack chocolate snack terry's
chocolate orange
i [ __ ] love terry shopping do you
have any chocolate orange i don't but
i've heard of it
they have in america do you have in
america yeah so it's basically just a
chocolate orange but
the [ __ ] best part of it is that it's
literally an
orange that you have to like smack and
you eat a little chocolate
right an average sized orange i don't
know what it is chocolate yeah it's just
it's just a bowl of solid chocolate that
you eat like an orange right and i don't
know what it is like
they have like the terry's chocolate
orange bars and i don't know what it is
about playing the mini game of
like [ __ ] smacking the chocolate and
peeling it yourself it just tastes so
much better and so much more satisfying
because you're working for it
i love just smacking it against my
concrete wall in my home just [ __ ]
who wants peace
it wants a piece of terrorist orange and
it's always really cheap as well it
always go on offer for like a pound
yeah so you've got like a way too much
chocolate for really cheap somehow it
was yeah i love that wait does it have
like actual orange in it or
it's like a orange chocolate flavor
right right really nice though
i really like it i don't really like
orange flavor because i think my
aunt i i think the only reason why i
know about chocolate orange because like
my aunt
like used to hand make like chocolate
orange but like actually get like
slices of orange and like coat it in
chocolate
and then like actually i've just figured
out what [ __ ] australians get
patriotic about what some reason
tim tams hell yeah
mid as [ __ ] australia [ __ ] you
i think i think the bourbon biscuits are
better in this show
i like every australian yeah has
actually like baked up tim tams
like extreme levels it's the only like
good snack we have debatable
i mean it just goes to show the quality
of the rest of our snacks right
i don't know man like i mean it's good
don't get me wrong but i'm
like tim tams or bar
toblerone i'll take the toolbar yeah to
be honest like there are better snacks
out there but tim sam's is just so
readily available in australia like
anywhere you go
that's just like it's comfort food
basically yeah yeah i mean i feel like i
remember i tried it for the first time
and i feel like we have like some
very similar yeah we have really similar
stuff in the uk isn't it like
penguins like kind of similar as well a
little bit yeah yeah penguins are great
though yeah pickles are great yeah yeah
um what else do we have in the uk oh
jaffa cakes
no jeffcoats yeah what do you think
about jaffa cakes pretty [ __ ]
okay good good cakes again that sounds
familiar sponge
cake with uh like orange juice
yeah yeah we have those in australia too
yeah yeah
they're all they have horrible shelf
life those things go bad
really fast yeah and like you know the
only time i ever ate them was at my
grandma's place
it's it the packet is big enough why
like you kind of have to do it in one
setting because
again yeah so
like if you buy them for yourself you've
got to commit to eating it's definitely
like a
home party snack whenever you go to any
gathering
or any kind of like eat like a camping
trip or something everyone always brings
out the jaffa cakes and i never
understood why
because it's the middle snack in england
in my opinion
and for some reason people think they
want people people think i want a piece
of that
you know right you want it i like the
taste of it i think it's nice but after
i have two i'm like you know what i'm
good for the next five years
i'm fine like i enjoy it though i mean
that's how i feel about kinder eggs
oh i [ __ ] love kinder eggs that's
great but i have like two
and i'm like this is so much sugar i'm
i'm about to go kenda
it's really [ __ ] good like kinder
eggs and a black hazelnut as well yeah
the hazelnut ones are amazing
um i'll bring you some when i when i
when i go home
arrow in australia yeah yeah yeah we do
we do
yeah yeah they're really like [ __ ]
fluffy chocolate not fluffy but like
they're really like
bubbly chocolate yeah
you know sometimes when you buy the
expensive chocolate like
lint or lindora
swiss chocolate yeah you know sometimes
you eat one and you're like that's good
it's good but do i really want like 10.
like it's not like a chocolate you eat
ten of
yeah i've not that's what i've noticed
about expensive chocolate it's like you
eat one and
you feel like you've just ate 10
chocolate bars in this one
yeah yeah and then you're like great i
paid 50 bucks for these 10 chocolates
like this time to give them away i guess
what i do now i don't really want to eat
these anymore that's why i like shitty
chocolate
it's like you could eat so much it's
like it's
so good like you never get bored of it
like dairy milk i never get bored of
that
i just can't even like really eat a lot
of chocolate anymore no
no neither yeah but big macs yeah hell
yeah okay
i'll oh dude i can smash a big mac back
every day if i want to mcflurry
[ __ ] yeah yeah i don't know i i ice
cream is uh i think my love is grown for
ice cream
really i get older but my love for
chocolate has gone down i don't know why
i think my my
chocolate is pretty mvp though yeah i
think my luffa chocolate and ice cream's
just kind of gone down recently i don't
know my my love for sweet things
has definitely gone down yeah you're
already sweet enough joey it's um
i definitely do like my savory and
saltier stuff better yeah because for me
like i think you know a lot of people
say you have a second stomach for
dessert i don't have a second stomach
that's [ __ ] i'm just like i'm just
like if if i have if i have
space in my stomach for more food then
i'm gonna eat more food yeah right right
exactly
right i mean if there is a tiramisu
available i will always make room for a
tiramisu
okay to be fair if a tiramisu comes out
i'm smashing that [ __ ]
that has to be my favorite cake what's
your favorite cake
a i don't know this is like asking an
alien made your favorite celebrity
i guess uh the human on the tv is my
favorite i guess if not like the default
chocolate cake then probably
red velvet i [ __ ] love red red velvet
is good red velvet
is probably like the only other cake
that i like like to eat
other than chocolate velvet is very good
yeah i can't eat a chocolate cake
anymore it's
it's just way too heavy now yeah it
depends like i never eat a chocolate
cake it's an old voice
i can never eat a chocolate cake after a
meal i just sometimes i just get a
random craving for a chocolate cake
right like like for me like i don't
really eat as much chocolate anymore
but sometimes i just get this random
craving for sweets and you know you
you know when you're [ __ ] you know
when you're hungry and you feel like
you can eat everything right yeah and so
when i get this chocolate craving i buy
like [ __ ]
i i [ __ ] like buy 10 different types
of chocolate bars chocolate ice cream
chocolate cake i'm just like
i'm [ __ ] craving this i'm hungry
enough to eat everything
i have one bite of the chocolate cake
and i'm just like okay i'm done now
[ __ ] i've made a massive mistake because
i just have
a table table full of just chocolate in
front of me that i know i don't want to
eat anymore
god but uh yeah i just i don't really
i'm not really i'm not a dessert guy
are you a dessert guy i mean i prefer
the main but sometimes some places have
like really good desserts and it
makes you feel like okay hold up could
you go have you ever been that's got a
point have you ever been to like uh
cake buffets is that way wrong that's a
thing
what is that oh oh okay where is this in
japan they're [ __ ] everywhere yeah
what
where yeah there's one there's one
really good one i went to in harajuku
where it's like
it's literally like a sushi train of
cakes of like tiny little cakes
how much how many can you have before
you start becoming sick i had like
four and then i was done but like some
of my female friends can have like you
know 10
15 of these guys i'm just like man you
guys are built different real food
nah sweet [ __ ] please sweet [ __ ] yeah i
like cupcakes cupcakes are nice
sound about a muffin or a cupcake i
think i've had a cupcake in like
five years it's just muffin that's like
muffins pretty easy
muffins pretty good science what is it
about muffins that are very british
something i think it's very american i'd
say yeah i think it's more american
when i think muffin i think british i
don't know maybe english muffins are you
thinking
uh could be yeah it could be because i
feel like definitely with dessert
dessert culture is way stronger in asia
than i feel when i was like living in
england
um because i didn't like until i moved
to thailand i went to thailand i didn't
know the concept
of just like a dessert bar where it's
just like a restaurant that just
specifically just serves desserts yeah
that's just not a thing in english
there's some like what oh was it like
casper's or whatever it's called
the [ __ ] is
i saw everywhere it was like a dessert
thing but it was like really tacky i
didn't really like the look of it yeah
like the the only kind of dessert
oriented places that i find in england
now are just
like they they are marketed as like
asian like dessert places right
and and that only started cropping up
more recent in more recent times i'm
not a fan of like how [ __ ] bright and
loud dessert places are
i feel like i'm you know what i mean
almost exclusively white as [ __ ] they're
always like really pastel colors or even
bright colors and i just feel like [ __ ]
i mean you get blind when you walk into
one i'm like
i want to just get a dessert not be
visually attacked all these [ __ ]
colors
i feel like i'm in the wrong place when
i go into there because i feel like i'm
i'm
too i'm too british for this i'm too sad
i can't i can't be in here i just hate
the fact that like all of them
all of the walls are just white as [ __ ]
and they blast the light on and i'm like
oh god it's too big
it's 2pm
it depends on the place yeah i mean you
get different types of uh
lighting and of walls or whatever the
[ __ ] i don't know yeah do you ever are
you one of those people who like
care about the mood of a restaurant like
yeah the lighting
yeah yeah yeah definitely helps with uh
get a feel for what the owner wanted
right
yeah i didn't start to care about it
until
kind of kind of like i say i would say
like my mid-20s
i mean yeah they got like they got to
like build the atmosphere before you
even sit down
yeah like they gotta like get you like
understanding the vibe what the food
yeah because before when i was like a
[ __ ] uni student or something
it's not not just restaurants i didn't
care about the bar vibe you know what i
mean
like to me if it's does it serve food is
it cheap can i eat it yeah true that's
all i cared about right
but like as i grown as i like grew older
i'm just like
damn sure
like the vibe from the place can really
affect if i'm enjoying my meal or drink
as much as usual and i didn't i don't
know i don't know if just like
something switched into my brain or
something but there's a part of me
that's like i feel
the if a restaurant has like really nice
mood or like a mood that is fitting and
is comforting yeah then it almost
sometimes blinds you to the fact that
the food might not be as good as you
think it is i know i mean there's plenty
of times where
it sets up like high expectations yeah
the food comes out and it's
interesting it's so disappointing
yeah right because it's it's especially
in japan right because i feel like
especially
in japan every place has a unique vibe
yeah every restaurant you go to looks
amazing it has like a unique
selling point um but that isn't always
that this isn't always uh that doesn't
always equate to good food yeah well it
doesn't always equate to amazing weirdly
enough it's like kind of the opposite in
japan where like the shittier the place
looks usually the better the food is
especially when it comes to like ramen
family owned restaurants and stuff like
that
yeah if the sign is falling apart in the
ramen place it's pretty pretty good
because i wouldn't give a [ __ ] about how
it looks
like i because that's how i feel about
thai food right because i
very rarely eat in like a thai
restaurant here
um and that's because for me growing up
in
not growing up but like whenever i go to
thailand some of the best food would be
street food
right so that that to me was like the
best kind of comfort food
that i would find and it's to me i'm
like not it's only when i'm like
really really missing thai food and
really craving it that i actually
go out and go to a restaurant but most
of the times i cook it myself because
it's to me it's like comfort food
there's something comforting about it
and
it's it's like you know it's like the
same with japan where you go to a ramen
shop if it's like a if it looks like a
high-class
prestigious ramen shop probably doesn't
taste as good as like the
the rundown family made ramen right yeah
yeah yeah
exactly yeah and uh yeah i guess
wrap it up there i guess we'll just wrap
it up there we'll jump right into the
ending yeah jump right into
oh these patrons patrons look at all
this gracious i bet they eat their
kitkats correctly yeah i definitely
i bet they don't use them so much
spreadable breakfast biscuits saliva i
think you're talking about viscous
breakfast spreads all right
hashtag biscuit biscuits breakfast it's
like a tongue twister
but hey if you like to support the show
then make sure to go to patreon.com also
follow us on twitter
uh meme us on the subreddit and uh if
you hate our face listen to us on
spotify
and uh yeah that's pretty much it i hope
you enjoyed get more
hot takes for food this episode we've
got like a bunch today
hot taste and tangent to the episode and
uh i guess we'll see you all next time
bye
[Music]
you